c'est un Suédois qui est remporté le
Nobel de médecine cette année le
généticien svanté peibo qui n'était pas
sur la courte liste des possibles
mobilisables
ça contribution scientifique est tout de
même remarquable il a littéralement
inventé la Paléo génomique l'étude des
gènes des espèces humaines disparues et
assez
gavage
[Musique]
qui ont réussi à séquencer pour la
première fois l'ADN de noumo
néandertalis une espèce éteinte depuis
près de 40 000 ans et à démontré qu'une
partie de l'humanité est porteuse de 2%
de gènes provenant des Néandertaliens
on a d'ailleurs découvert tout récemment
que la covid semble frapper plus
sévèrement les gens qui sont porteurs de
gemmes de Néandertaliens essentiellement
des Européens et certains groupes
d'asiatiques
qui a aussi participé à la découverte
d'une autre espèce disparue l'homme de
déni sauvant a reçu une somme
équivalente à plus de 1 million 200000
dollars canadiens avec son prix Nobel
Haven conseiller
le père du chercheur suédois a lui aussi
remporté un prix Nobel de médecine en
1982 pour des recherches liées aux
hormones ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal